amber heard is some celebrity lady i
guess she was married to johnny depp who
is a much better known celebrity man
and uh she accused him of doing all
sorts of terrible things to her but then
it turns out it looks like she did a lot
of terrible things to him and now
they're in court talking about this and
uh during this time in court they played
a clip of of this woman sounding like a
complete lunatic
i said to travis i said no i said to you
hey
tell travis what just happened are you
telling me to do it you told me to you
said go do that i said no tell him what
you're saying i lied and that you
punched me in the right
thing you figured it out and you said no
i didn't what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
and i watched you lie and then i didn't
punch you by the way you i'm sorry that
i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched don't tell me
what it feels like to be punched you
know you've been a lot of fights you've
been around a long time i don't know
you didn't get punched you got hit i'm
sorry i hit you like this but i did not
punch you i did not [ __ ] deck you i
was hitting you i don't know what the
motion of my actual hand was but you're
fine i did not hurt you i did not punch
you i was hitting you
how what am i supposed to do do this
i'm not sitting here about it am i you
are that's the difference between me and
you your [ __ ] baby
because you started you are such a baby
girl the [ __ ] up johnny physical fights
i did start a physical fight you did
because
yes you did so you did the right thing
the big thing the you know what you are
admirable
okay so this woman is admitting to doing
all the stuff that she accused her
ex-husband of doing to her she's
obviously a complete lunatic i don't
have any real sympathy or anything for
her uh except that
i can't really join the pity party
entirely for johnny depp because
the guy needs to get control of his
household okay the guy needs to lead
okay
to quote tony soprano whatever happened
to strong men whatever happened to the
quiet silent type whatever happened to
gary cooper
okay what you're what you're seeing
happen here
at the level of this family such as it
is and the family is the building block
of society so it's the fundamental
political unit you're seeing it
throughout the entire society is just
complete disorder
complete disorder
i i don't know what spark came between
these two that led them to get married
in the first place but something tells
me it might not have been totally uh the
most virtuous of reasons and there was
total disorder here he wasn't leading
his family she's a complete lunatic and
was was allowed to just do whatever she
wanted it it's
there was a line in the crown
speaking of hollywood the show about the
queen in the royal family which is that
it's in the little things that the rot
begins it's in the little things the
little things you just let people get
away with the little the little
injustices that you just let go
unanswered and then that spreads and
that spreads like a cancer throughout
society and that there is no question
when you introduce the insane amount of
disorder into the family that we have in
the last 50 years into the political
community for instance by erasing our
national borders that we have in the
last 50 years when you the kind of
disorder where you give a handful of
oligarchs the control over all of speech
you know when you introduce this kind of
radical social disorder your political
system is going to go
insane the answer to that is not some
long soliloquy about freedom in the
abstract or equality in the abstract or
rights in the abstract the answer is get
a hold of your political community
bring some stability and order back to
the family bring some stability and
order back to the borders but we need
order in the country before we can talk
about any of these sorts of things
otherwise the political system is going
to go up in flames what do you think i
had for dinner on saturday i think you
know saturday in the knolls household
means
good ranchers i had delicious
new york strip steaks that was for me
and sweet little alisa cute baby june
had his better than organic chicken with
the delicious good ranchers garlic rub
on top which is just enough to really
spice up the flavor but not too much
it's not overwhelming you can still put
your own spin on it it's just
magnificent i love these guys the beef
is extraordinarily high quality it
the the craziest part of it all is that
right now we're in this historic moment
where food prices are going through the
roof and good ranchers is giving you the
opportunity not only to get actual good
american beef but to lock in your price
so you can lock in your price right now
even though the prices are getting
higher as summer approaches you can lock
it in and get a thirty dollar discount
on prime stakes and better than organic
chicken today goodranchers.com
knowles to save on the quality that
you've been looking for go to good
ranchers right now take the guesswork
out of the grocery store shop local have
it shipped to your door use codenals can
wles and enjoy your box of 100 american
meat and your 30 savings order now to
combat inflation with good ranchers
american meat delivered i'm glad you
like that clip now
ring the bell subscribe get all those
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you